as I mentioned earlier YouTube is doing
they're proud to love campaign right now
people are putting up videos using
hashtag proud to love about who they
love why they love what they love and
that is exactly the question that I'm
going to pose to all of you in order I
have a sense we know what you love
Johnny but bring it anyway I mean I
would like to first say that I'm proud
to love all of America's tight and young
muscular John
Lumberjacks military man travels tall
man short a man man with a big fine man
with a juicy booty man with a for Johnny
one minute I would tell you I'm proud to
love the gay family that we create for
ourselves that's something pretty
magical that gay people been able to do
surround yourself with your family so
I'm proud to live on my gay family I'll
see you out there boo-boo love you baby
Hannah who or what or how or why do you
like current events ya know I'm proud to
love you know this is probably not as
good for me as it is but I really really
love cheese and I just everyday I think
about its first thing I think about when
I wake up um no but in all seriousness
and I have to say that's just cuz my
community is so good to me I love my
online community I love the group of
hard to sexuals that are out there
wanting to do good together and impact
the world in a positive open-minded way
yeah I do love cheese too right am i
right oh jeez lovers a bad name the gay
guys usually don't eat cheese in front
of each other I feel like lesbians are
willing to eat the first I've heard of
it you never where are you headed out
gay guys don't eat bread I know I've
been spending too much time in West
Hollywood and miss whitney mixter who or
what or why are you proud well I must
say I agree with you I am also proud to
live cheese as well but I'm proud to of
my wife and I'm also proud at the fact
that I can get married again for the
third time it's a charm
but now legally in this beautiful state
of California I'm living as an outlaw
but I'm also proud that we are
re-examining kind of our mentality on
marriage in love and what it what it
means in this country and I'm proud that
there are still people out there like
Wendy Davis who is willing to stand for
13 hours straight without and it all
works out try to speak in it and make it
now or why or what
what are you proud of yeah my husband
proud to love my son that's a whole kind
of thing that I didn't imagine was
possible when I was a kid so the fact
that I'm living that dream is exciting
to me every day I am proud to be part of
this radical minority because it's
always the radical minority in America
that pushes this country forward
it's never the majority that wakes up
one morning and goes hey you know what
let's free the slaves
hey let's let women vote that's a good
idea it's always a radical minority
always starts off as a small voice that
knows what's true and knows what's just
and I'm really proud to be a part of
this movement
[Music]
all right Brady got an applause break
who are you proud to level or why or
well I am proud to love my parents
because they are the most amazing human
beings and I was so scared to admit this
part of myself to them and the way they
handled it I am just so proud to be
their daughter because my my dad we went
on a walk and he brought it up out of
nowhere and he looked at me and he was
like I was about to tell him and he was
like you don't have to say anything and
he just hugged me and he's like I just
want you to be happy it doesn't matter
who with and I was like okay
I'm the luckiest girl in the entire
world applause for the dad all right
well I guess I have to answer this
myself I would say I'm prouder more than
anything else about timing right now we
are in something that is so cool the
fact that you guys whether you're gay or
straight or bi or trans or robot we are
questioning there's a lot of letters the
fact that it's actually it's become cool
that this thing that like I feared my
whole life that I think most of us did
that we thought was something broken in
us is actually cool now and I'm with my
straight friends like they actually
think it's cool that I'm gay and it's